welcome back to Collider heroes did I am
Amy Dallen I'm coach Andrew and we are
delighted to welcome today a legendary
comic book artist the illustrator and
co-creator of the Bowie's welcome Derek
Robertson hello I know man good I am in
love with your work thank you in advance
just as a fan like holy crap thanks for
joining us I'm so happy to be here and
and I'm a fan of your work too coy we
were talking just before the cameras
rolled about really excited what you're
doing to elevate the comic book people
to the Hollywood level exposure and
thank you for having me I'm really I had
to be a part of this thank you
well you're thinking us for that but
literally your comic book baby's about
to hit Amazon yes everyone's mind has
been preemptively renewed for a second
season I was so happy they said it at
calm because I've been walking around
like biting my tongue he told me a while
back and he's like don't tell anyone I'm
like okay I won't
refresh is refreshing why is that the
convention they go now we're doing
season two I'm like weight off my
shoulders first of all can you tell us
what's the story of the boys okay it's a
in in the boys I'm not sure how much is
visible behind me on camera here okay
it's about these guys if if the
superheroes really existed they would be
in our world the premise is that they
would be horribly corrupted by the power
and fame and and corporate greed that
infects everything in our real world
including the superheroes so in the
front of everybody's imagination there
are the movies and the action figures
and the comic books in this world too
but it's all propaganda it's all out
there to like make you think that
they're these wonderful self-sacrificing
heroes went behind the scenes they're
terrible people and they don't care
about anybody but their selves in their
bottom line doesn't sound like any power
structure we might relate to at all
so fiction yeah you know weird world
where powerful people are corrupt so the
so the seven are not only physically
powerful they're also protected by this
corporation called vada Nash
which sell their services to cities that
they can go and protect but for price
and that's the quiet part but in what
happens and then back in the day when we
were creating the comic Ennis and I we
he theorized like you know you see all
these superhero battles where cars are
flying and buildings are falling and
nobody ever gets hurt somebody's
grandmother might be under that car and
I'm like wow that's really true
so we built the comic based on that
premise like somebody needs to hold
these people accountable can I swear
like pg-13 okay I almost I want her to
let an f-bomb fly I want to just check
and make sure I'm not ruining her
broadcast it's my dancing 10 minutes of
the day but this is the idea that the
there they're terrible people but
somebody needs to hold them accountable
well that's what the boys comes in so
the boys are weird team of five people
in the comic that work as a black ops
organization or black ops part of the
CIA
and have government authority and Billy
butcher flashes a badge you never see
intentionally that gives him authority
to basically patrol spy on keep tabs on
the superheroes because not only in the
comic they could physically take them on
in the show they've tweaked it to where
they have to outsmart them which
actually ups the ante for their danger
level but the in the comic it was the
idea that they could take them on and
police them so when you're in trouble
and here come the boys you know and the
female is one of the boys I love that
this book felt not only like the real
world but there were reflections of the
real world in it and one of my favorites
I just have to say and the casting is
now reflected Simon Pegg is the father
yeah that was I can finally talk about
this this was one of my favorite okay
I'm gonna take for anybody that doesn't
know this story at this point because
Simon Pegg went and told it on James
Corden they held my heart up on The Late
Late Show and I was like
they held the art of okay because they
never like they most people think only
one person does a comic they they go
it's an artist and a writer that worked
together but the artist usually gets
overlooked because because a lot of
times that's multiple artists - yeah in
some ways it is taken a long time for
some of these stories to make it to the
screen but the hopefully nice element is
that now it's happening in a time where
I'd like to think it is becoming more
standard to pay attention to the people
who make this difference I still notice
that it's Garth Ennis is the boys a lot
and nothing against you know I'm super
happy for Garth - I think this is a it's
just one of those things where you know
when an artist works on a comic and
designs everything we both started with
blank paper I'll put it that way and I
did a lot of research and a lot of time
spent you know developing ideas and some
of the ideas that made it to the final
or were mine originally I wanted to make
the female Japanese and Garth changed
his mind and agreed with that so that
was wonderful like we close
collaboration you know we collaborated
wonderfully on when we created this book
and it was a real labor of love and we
had a lot of fun creating this so to be
left out of the final like and it's this
one person's thing it always makes ago
but he didn't draw it even but in these
costumes look law like so much like the
costumes from the comic that I feel
amazing oh it's wonderful I got a I have
a lovely photo which I had planned ahead
of I got to go to set last September and
I stood with all of them in costume but
that was like the most magical day of my
life I was told like don't there was a
really intense scene that you'll see in
season one and I had met a couple of the
actors the day before on set so I hadn't
met everybody but Kripke was nervous and
he just said hey it's an intense day
please hang back as much as possible
meeting the creator of the comic might
make some of them some of these people
nervous so just I said know whatever you
need I was just happy to be there I'm
like Ringo and the Beatles just happy so
I'm like you know I'll hide under a
chair and peek if that's what's
necessary so no no just hang back
because it's gonna be an intense scene
so I was like okay don't talk to the
actors very I got it hadn't met Anthony
yet and so like but to get to the area
where my they had that little director's
chair
my name everything everything 10 year
old me thought may never happen was like
happening but so but to get to the
little area the you to that you sit and
sit down the director and watching a
monitor you had I had to pass through
the hallway where everybody was prepping
for the scene getting made up so they
were all sitting across from each other
full costume in their chairs and I came
walking through and I had met somebody
I'd met the day before I met Aaron the
day before and on a different set out of
costume and she's like Derek and then
next thing you know like everybody's
talking to me and I was like I felt like
I was breaking the rules no no man it's
good it's good and then I saw this
lovely picture where they all got put me
in the middle and they all were posing
with me and I was just like these are my
characters you know like these are the
guys that I did you know a media Anthony
in full costume as the helm Lander said
to me at that moment he's just homeland
you know it was the poster they released
looking up at them gave us all I think
all like chills chills down our spines
cuz like that's that it's that they're
doing the actual it really looks like
Mike I mean they stayed so true it was
most beautiful about walking around on
set to is that I had never you know of
course really been that deeply involved
in a shoot before like you know where
I'm there on I was there for three days
and they couldn't pull me off you know
actually we're super kind and like can
you stay another day because we're
shooting this thing tomorrow cool they
were wonderful and and so but what was
amazing is seeing it all come together
but you're on these indoor sets with
fake sunlight coming in the windows that
it starts to feel natural and that you
forget that you're on a set so it's
kinda like being in a casino where like
there's no time no time at all and I'm
watching this a night and because I just
love storytelling and the collaborative
process even in an abstract I was loving
scene like then shoot these scenes over
and over and over again it didn't get
wearisome to me I'm like why do they go
in
and I was able to like what was wrong
with that you know yeah we just like
we're gonna see if we can get a
different intonation and to watch these
professionals change it up just ever so
slightly each time until they got it
just just so yeah really amazing so
which means me back to simon pegg it's
my Mutant power I can always pick up a
three depending on how late in the night
at con it is second drink maybe not so
so I meet Simon years ago when I was
creating the comic with Garth we had a
few years to work on it because we were
both busy and I had to fulfill some
contractual obligations and I was
finishing up transmitter Politan and
quick for those in the audience we will
talk about this later but trans
metropolitan a legendary work of
science-fiction also co-created by Derek
and in just an incredible work I'll be
back here discussing that at some point
I'd be happy to the fact that I'm not
internet arrest Thompson at this point
the interview yet is America will get
their good news I'll come back the bad
news I'll come back but Simon is so
Simon was only known what wasn't known
at all in the United States at this
point I'm my good friend Gary Widow who
I'm currently creating a series called
Oliver for Image Comics Gary Witter is
the writer of Star Wars rogue one he he
created the Book of Eli with Denzel
Washington that was his creation and
screenplay so Gary and I have been good
friends since before those projects even
happened and we started working on
Oliver forever ago but he had loaned me
this is how long ago this was VH at
state if you children out there is how
we used to experience media they but he
loaned me these tapes of a show called
spaced yes which I had never seen but he
said you're gonna love this and so I'm
there watching it's the first thing that
Edgar Wright and Nick Frost and Simon
Pegg did
there and it's wonderful and now luckily
it's on Amazon you can get it but for a
long time you could only get bootleg
tapes you know people that taped it off
TV that's what I was watching with PVC
tapes that he had saved but I'm watching
that while and I at the same time like
the only character that wasn't coming
together and the early sketches for me
was Huey and it was partially because
Garth actually has a friend that they
call wee Huey and I've met Huey he's
lovely person but I'd only met him a
handful of times and I didn't have any
photographs of him so while I remembered
his personality very well I couldn't
draw him from memory very well and it
wasn't feeling right the early sketches
of Huey don't look right and I was
trying to figure out like I can see him
in my head I can feel him at this point
but I don't he doesn't look right on it
he wasn't coming out of my hand the
right way he looked to maturity look to
angry he looked to he was bald but it
made him look like he was going to kick
your ass
and he we shouldn't have a vulnerability
but he also shouldn't look like a
pushover so I was just trying to get
that balance and I'm watching spaced and
there's this wonderful funny guy who is
an aspiring comic book artist who works
at a comic book store and this is Simon
Pegg and I'm like that's him that's Huey
so I did a really quick sketch and I
have an interesting picture to show you
off camera but he looks like so I did
this rough sketch of him real fast like
I froze the appositive tape and I drew
out a bad shot of what I thought Huey
would look like if Simon Pegg played him
and sent that to Garth he's like yeah
that works i he liked it so that was it
and I didn't think much of it other than
then this rumors of this movie shaun of
the dead was getting real popular so I
did I found some stills online of Shaun
of the Dead and I drew from that and
then we released the cast drawings like
my character creations I think bleeding
cool broke the news and the next thing I
know Simon Pegg is I'm find out like
he's blowing up in the United
because the sound of the dead in these
in Mission Impossible and all the stuff
is going on at the time we've already
announced the book he's on the cover I
didn't think he'd ever even see it you
know but it was the which was really
stupid on my part because he clearly
loves and I don't recommend anybody do
this again I really I really drew the
one in a million card on this stupid
thing because I might add to redraw a
lot of comics before we released but
luckily rich Johnston put us in touch
and I got this lovely email where the
subject line was me Huey and I and I
wrote this long apology to it saying I'm
so sorry I did I really just love your
work I thought you were great for the
character I will change it if you want
me to it's not too late we haven't gone
to press with number one yet and he
ruined the night saying goes no this is
the best things happened to me all day
and I've already jumped through a plate
glass window so you said by all means I
love your work I love Garth's work I
would love to be in the comic it's no
problem on our way you were the best
thank you
and then but then DC was like no that's
a problem he now could sue us you guys
he's got to sign a release and you have
to ask and I'm like your papers really
no can we please not he said it said
yeah but this is DC Warner Brothers and
they're like let's make sure it's cool
so universe where he owns DC now I think
that's where everybody's cold sweats it
to be guys but so I wrote him back and I
said I so sorry I have to ask you this
and he said you know what how little
they know us both it's totally fine and
I sent him the cover art to number four
as a thank you because it's like the
best drawing had done to him to date and
we've remained good friends since then
and I got it again don't draw Simon into
your comic this is gonna work out for
you I got very very lucky but at the
same time so years later okay so 2008
we get cancelled and and then picked up
by Dynamite Entertainment which is run
with the book ever since and been 100%
supportive weird day of my life I'll
tell you another time about waking up
ready to ink my hip book and being told
there is no hip book anymore but uh and
not understanding why but then I when we
got over to dynamite I just lost the
train of thought that I said I will do
my Mutant power is failing me it'll come
back in just a second but we had because
then I started thinking about being
cancelled oh call Hollywood comes
knocking and Hollywood comes knocking
and then we got optioned in 2008 and I
was so excited that because it just felt
like everything was snowballing in the
right direction that you know so we I
was under contract with Marvel and just
bought a house and was being released
from my contract to go work on the boys
so I bought a house at two small
children and suddenly no job so we were
cold panic at the first but then we got
optioned for the movie and and we
thought this was all going to happen so
I took a trip to New Orleans with my
wife to celebrate and we were walking
around and I found this little
back-alley shoe shop and they had these
ridiculously cool like rock star level
boots that like they were like electric
blue with a fleur-de-lis on the side and
I have a one of my only tattoos as a
fleur-de-lis cuz I lived in Italy so it
was they look like they were just you
know like that moment where they like
there's not a spotlight on them and
there's not there are no angel singing
but in my mind that's how it happened
yeah hey boots that's a good word for
them so I but I'm like as I tend to be a
Mike easier too good for me and so I
left the shop but I couldn't get him out
of my head so the next day I tracked
down this shop again and I tried him on
and I bought him but I told my wife I
said I'm gonna wear these on the red
carpet when the movie comes out and I
put him in the not not until so I put
them in my closet and then the movie
never happened
the year after year went by went into
turn around it kept saying now they Adam
McKay who has had become friends with is
a wonderful person was gonna write and
direct it before he got all kinds of
awesome
so we had like the creme de la creme
director writer and for whatever reason
people was just too terrified to do this
movie and my friends Phil hey Matt
Manfredi had written the screenplay and
it was good but it was kind of a pg-13
script because that's what they were
being directed to do and then Adam came
in it's like let's rated-r and it was
great and I got to see little animatics
of like what he went here he was doing
everything you could to sell this movie
and he just could not get the green
light and so year after year for our
family you know I'm a comic book artist
you know I'm rolling large we're managed
to make the bills and I managed to keep
employed and but you know year after
year with this thing was I got to the
point where I like it's never gonna
happen and I'm hearing stories from a
lot of people like this happens I know
it just happened Dave Peterson a mouth
guard and then my like why that's not
happening and that's just the politics
of of this beast because everything's
Hollywood is this one thing and it's not
it's like it's as random wouldn't be
more thing Hollywood is the sign on the
hill that's it everything else is on
lots of people doing a lot of different
projects and there are people right now
like hey this is getting made ones that
guinea man I'm like no it's actually the
ants under the hill okay right you don't
mean we just see the Mount but it's the
ant
absolutely it's it's its it just doesn't
work that way I have no influence on
what product Amazon may or may not make
so this is just I'm just happy to be
here I got lucky once I drew Simon Pegg
right and coming back to that
so Simon Pegg we everybody wanted him to
be Huy but as early as 2009 he's like
I'm too old for the role and he told me
this privately too as well as he would
say it publicly so I knew he wasn't just
being humble he was really like and I
think he was more like in his 20s I'm in
my 40s you know and so I was like hey I
don't think they're the characters
age-specific I just hope you're in it
and he's like well but he had his
reservations so
when the TV show got launched yeah that
was all happening the first thing I I
got in there was like have you spoken to
Simon Pegg and that didn't hear anything
didn't hear anything and and then one
day I wrote again because I'm like have
you reached out Simon Pegg about maybe
doing a cameo or so yeah and he and
Kripke's reply was he's right here in my
office now don't tell anyone and I'm
like yeah so big day in the Robertson
house where we were like like
celebrating because Simon's kindness is
a lot of the reason this has always had
a good ambassador he's always spoken
well the other thing so and then he's
Huey's dad which was like my dream page
because if you can't be Huey at least be
there with you and then he's been great
with Jack and Jack waited going back to
that original drawing I did of him a
space when I was drawn Simon I recently
found that drawing and did a side by
side with what I was what I was trying
to draw what I drew but then when he
looked at Jack Wade's face next to that
drawing it weirdly looks more like Jack
than it does like Simon and that's a
complete coincidence and if you think
I'm lying I have it on my phone I'll
show it to you when we're off care I
want to hear so much more about how this
came together about the show yes we're
so excited to get out in the world I do
have to ask though what about the boots
now the boots favorite so I didn't wear
them they had in my closet for ten years
and every once in a while I'd catch a
glimpse of them and go what might have
been you know but I brought them with me
for the San Diego big premiere and I was
like I'm just gonna wear him to the
party that's good enough but then they
called me out on the red carpet and so I
got to be on camera with Aaron and Carl
and all these and be a part of things
and I wore those boots on the carpet
yeah but the craziest thing was as I'm
leaving the door to go onto the red
carpet there's a man in a hat standing
there behind the you know on the velvet
rope side mm-hmm
having a chat and I looked and I went
and I walked and then I went back I'm
like Giancarlo and he looked at me went
and I go do you remember me and he goes
yes and he goes because four years
before we were at a convention in a
Zeeland together and we went to Hobbiton
together and we ended up walking around
Hobbiton hanging out in front of bilbo
baggins house and got to know each other
a little bit he's a lovely person but we
were sharing stories and he's a good
friend of Samuel Jackson's and he was
like telling me how he golfs of Sam
Jackson and one of those things that
comes up in a friendly conversation you
should come golfing with us sometime and
I was like I don't call but I would love
to know these boots never happened but I
was happy to at least be considered but
what was funny was is like we don't move
on it a little bit and but in this
moment on the red carpet he says what
are you doing here and I'm like I wonder
what you're doing here but I said the
went remember when you told me you golf
with Samuel Jackson they said yes and I
said remember I told you that he I've
been told he's a fan of a comic book
that I drew because he told Ryan Lee
wasn't no golden Apple where he shops
that he really likes the boys and I
think for a brief minute there when the
movie stages he might have been Mother's
Milk that could just be a rumor because
I know we're doing media right now but
um that's what I heard but I mean that
would have been awesome
but he's because he's pretty amazing
Nick Fury but they said I said remember
I told you that you know he likes my
comic book and that they had optioned it
for a movie cuz it was four or five
years ago and he goes yes I go this is
that movie and he went this is you this
is you and I said yeah and I and he goes
and he threw his arms around me goes I'm
so happy for your dream came true and I
was wearing my boots and I told him the
story of the boots and he's like your
dream came true man and so for the rest
of night and I go but what are you doing
here goes I'm in season two Internet if
you write something never let it die
keep persevering by the boots and don't
draw Simon Pegg because that one option
is taken but believe in yourself because
sometimes this happens we will
definitely have you back on cuz I gotta
talk Hunter s Thompson I gotta talk
Wolverine
I gotta talk all the things thank you so
very very much a real pleasure
I appreciate it can't wait to everyone
again thank you come back any time
thank you all we'll see you next time
and stay sweaty